I'm Rachel Zuraw. I'm, live here in San Francisco. I'm an attorney
specializing in intellectual properties, especially pharmaceutical
and biotechnology, with a background in bio-ethics.
>> You know, what are the ethical issues surrounding the
use of specifically HeLa cells in the case of Henrietta's story.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But also the issue of using tissues from
people without their consent in general.
>> The researchers who took the cells from Henrietta's you've already covered.
You know, they were attempting There were multiple attempts to find this
immortal cell line. And, they were taking samples from anyone they could. She
was there for therapeutic treatment, when they took the cell line. And,
at the time that the cells were
harvested from Henrietta Lacks. The Nuremberg trials
of the Nazi physicians who participated in
medical experiments, well quasi medical experiment in
the concentration camps. The one of the first principles to come out of the
Nuremberg trials is that voluntary consent of
a human research subject is absolutely essential.
And that's been embroidered on in United States law and ethical guidelines ever
since. The informed consent, that any individual
participating in research needs to be told
beforehand. They need to have all of the information that they are able to
understand so that they can agree or not. To participate in the research.
>> It must be fully voluntary.
>> It must be fully voluntary. Fully informed and
fully voluntary. You can't make a voluntary choice
to participate if you don't have all of
the information. Informed consent in the United States
in the early 1950s was still a, a
good theory. You know, everyone thought that
this, this sounded like a great idea. But
then you have an uneducated patient in
the hospital who doesn't understand what treatment she's
receiving, is not advocating for herself, and in the, in the context of the time
most physicians would not have paused to think
I should explain to her why I'm taking
this tissue sample. And let her know what I'm going to do with
it. Today, and we can discuss some other examples, that sort of behavior still
goes on. But it's a. Recognized by the medical establishment to be an
actual intrusion and invasion of the patient's
autonomy, of the human research subject's autonomy.
>> Right, now obviously things have changed since then and
>> Incrementally.
[LAUGH]
>> Okay, incrementally then.
>> It's leaps and bounds, maybe not as much as we would've liked.
[LAUGH]
>> Well, I want you to speak to that for a second
then. Did the Henrietta Lacks' story change anything, if not at the
time, eventually? And, if not that, were there other cases that, you
know, had a bigger impact on how we look at informed consent?
>> Well, the Henrietta Lacks' story is, you know, wasn't known for more than
40 years, so when the Immortal Life
of Henrietta Lacks was released and Rebecca Skloot
started publicizing this story, then, I think, the story has now become part of
a really interesting movement towards control over personal genetic information.
Which, I think we're really just seeing the beginnings of. Because
legally, there was never a recognized right of
ownership or control of your, well, in the past,
tissues, blood sample et cetera, before genetic information
could be extracted and used from those samples.
>> Mm hmm
>> But now, you know, Henrietta Lacks, you mentioned
that her descendants Are now sitting on a committee to
authorize the use of the genetic information from the Hela
cells. Likewise there is a really interesting decision in 2010,
regarding a small Indian tribe that lives
in the Grand Canyon, who had given blood
samples to a University of Arizona researcher for,
to be used in diabetes and schizophrenia research.
one of the members of the tribe found
out several years after these blood samples were
donated that they were being used for purposes
that the tribe members had not consented to.
The university of Arizona, of course, argued that this was
perfectly acceptable, they had the samples, they had no right of
ownership to the samples. However, the ultimate outcome of this case, is
the, the tribe was able to dictate that they
would not authorize their blood samples to be used for anything other than the
original intended purpose. And actually, all of
the samples that they donated were destroyed.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So I mean, these are just a couple of isolated examples.
Case by case situations. Not really setting the precedent for how we're
going to be managing genetic information that are, that is in the
hands of researchers. But, it's indicative
of an interesting movement towards people becoming
aware of and taking measures to control the use of their genetic information.